aquí
[Música]
mi nombre es mil en la soledad moreno
soy filósofa soy profesora de filosofía
y en mis 23 años de ejercicio y la
docencia he descubierto algunas verdades
una de ellas
es que no todos los profesores hemos
sido buenos alumnos
recuerdo mi último año de secundario
filosofía tenía la profesora maravillosa
encantadora me gustaba escucharla
pero no le entendían a saber
consecuencia de ello me serví la materia
mesa dictamen tribunal
moreno que bolita preparado
la profesora
no estudie moreno porque no estudio
presentar porque lo hizo
mire profesora yo voy a ser astronauta y
en la luna no hay filosofía y por eso
usted me tiene que aprobar
los miembros del tribunal se levantaron
y se fueron ella me dice por favor me
entregué el boletín
tenemos boletín
y tomo su lapicera de forma tan delicada
en vez de poner un número
hizo un arte
y me la entregó
yo tomé el boletín y es pie y ella
sabiendo que había espiado me dice
moreno este 6 que usted se ha ganado sin
trabajar y sin sacrificio la vida se lo
va a cobrar en cada fracaso de su vida
profesora póngame en uno
ella se levantó cruzó los brazos y me
dijo moreno
no se pueden borrar los 21 de las
libretas así que tenga usted muy buenas
tardes
y me dijo con un 6 absolutamente
terrorífico
solo
en un aula fría
y con una esperanza de vida muy breve
al otro año entré y quería ser maestro
entré para hacer al magisterio
no termine
/ ec seminario quería ser sacerdote
de existir
pero entre el magisterio y el seminario
tuve la gran fortuna de conocerla a ella
hermosa
la filosofía no
y esta aprendiz su idioma
el griego antiguo para poder hablar con
ella y planificar toda nuestra vida
juntos eso me llevó a estudiar afuera
grecia y recibirme de filósofo y no de
astronauta evidentemente el vaticinio de
mi profesor estaba cobrando vida
hace una semana le pregunté a mis
alumnos entre varias preguntas
qué cosas google todavía no nos ha
respondido
alejandro un alumno que se parece a mí a
su edad se levantó me entrego la hoja y
cuando fui a mi escritorio a leer la
respuesta sentí que mi alma se destruía
por completo
alejandro había escrito
ojalá que google les enseñe a los
docentes a enseñar bien lo que explican
y así
volví a preguntarme cuál es nuestro
verdadero rol docente
si teníamos que humanizar nuestra tarea
pero que es humanizar nuestra tarea
quizás humanizar nuestra tarea tenga que
ver con construir nos y desconstruir nos
constantemente pero que sería una cosa y
otra bueno quizás construir nos sea
que entremos al aula todos los días con
el mismo entusiasmo y la misma esperanza
que entramos el primer día
y desconstruir nos y bueno también me
imagino que debes construir nos tendría
que ser algo como que nosotros seamos
nuestros propios alumnos
que podamos
cautivarnos
que podamos asombrarnos que podemos
contagiarnos el placer por lo que
hacemos
porque como el bostezo se contagia la
alegría también se contagia
nuestros alumnos se transforman con
nuestra transformación
somos experiencia
no somos una pantalla que proyecta
contenido nada más vivimos con ellos ese
momento
pero
porque esto no sucede porque cuando
entramos al aula o antes de entrar
escuchamos a los alumnos está bien
hoy sí viejo que tiene un olor
o que digan para qué línea clase o que
otros digan cuando termine el año
no nos acostumbramos a escuchar cosas
lindas y saben por qué
porque los docentes tenemos miedo
miedo
aquí
miedo a la pregunta de los alumnos
y aunque parezca contradictorio sí
habilitar la pregunta
es habilitar desactivando nuestro miedo
es posibilitando que el otro se sienta
libre con nosotros y nosotros con el
recuerdo mi primer día de clase luego de
mi operación de reasignación de sexo
primer día de clase les invito a mis
alumnos cuál era nuestra manera de
trabajar durante todo el año y tuve la
maravillosa idea sin duda alguna de
preguntar alguien tiene alguna pregunta
horrible fue lo peor que hice porque
empecé a ver como 35 desconocidos me
querían sacrificar a los dioses
y se escuchaban y se codeaban y
murmuraban y yo ahí y sol y también una
pobrecita
hasta que una niña
levantó la mano
valentina
profesora
hija
usted
toma prueba
y vimos todos como una nube gigante
inmensa salía por la ventana del aula
eran nuestros miedos nuestros miedos que
se iban y no vinieron durante todo el
año
[Música]
habilitar la pregunta es habilitar la
respuesta pero no la de los libros las
reales
porque que sería de una clase de
filosofía sin preguntas que sería de la
vida sin preguntas
la pregunta
en el aula fortalece la confianza y
disipar el miedo
porque el aula
es un espacio de preparación para la
vida
y lo que no se dice en el aula no se
dice en la vida
la escuela no debe reproducir jamás
violencia discriminación desigualdad
bullying atraso la escuela es un espacio
de vida
de vida de verdad
recuerdo
mi primer día de clase como docente
sala de profesores todos mis colegas
poquito más antiguos aconsejándome
claramente
cuidado con vengan con fulano no lo que
quiere hacer
era nada no negocie muy bien
en la clase formidable maravillosa
vuelvo a la sala de profesores cierro la
puerta de la sala y escucho moreno usted
me debe algo
me doy vuelta
y era mi antigua profesora de filosofía
claro vergüenza alegría por dios no
sabía que iba a hacer
y la abracé y le dio un beso que quiere
que haga
habían pasado muchos años y se olvidó no
se me olvida voy a tomar el examen y me
lo tomo
creo que es aquí un 7 o un poquito más
no sé
y le dije profesora por favor le pido
por favor
que me saque el vaticinio que me puso
cuando fui a rendir y ese me miró como
de qué cosas hablar
y le comenté y le recordé lo que ustedes
está saben de ella
bajo la mirada
un rato
la levantó
puso
sus dos manos arrugadas en mi cara
y me dijo moreno
a partir de ahora
usted iluminará a sus alumnos y será
iluminado por ellos
[Aplausos]
[Música]